avail tonight for the giants will be the
veteran right-hander johnny cueto plato
34 years of age he is in his 13th year
at the big league level 5 11 230 pounder
he's making start number six 1-0 on the
year with a 4-6-2 era
here's the one-two fletcher punching one
through the right side there's a base
hit with the shift on
saw what was open and took what was
given to him on the hill tonight for the
angels will be patrick sandoval sandoval
is a 23 year old rookie
and he's six 390 pounds and this is what
he's done in three starts in fact he's
made 12 starts in his young career he's
never had a big league win shoots it to
right is it gonna carry and it gets past
goodwin
slater on the move he'll head to third
and the giants have runners at the
corners
[Applause]
popped up into right field it'll be
goodwin
and the giants are going to strand a
pair here in the first
inning driven down the left field line
into the corner and that's going to be
up against the wall on one hop
so fletcher's got both hits against
cueto
mongolia rolls it off of rindon it's
going to kick under the glove of
fletcher
slater sees everything in front of him
so he's going to move over to third
should be a hit for longoria and flores
is going to have another shot at it
longoria he goes
high drive to left down the line it is
out of here
and the giants lead
three nothing
he drives it into left center field hit
very well
and
up against the wall on one hop trout
digs it out crawford's got a double
slater's single and he's walked slater
it's a high drive to left
up and back
out of here
and it's five to nothing
[Applause]
he's on the mound facing yastrimsky
and yaskrimsky doesn't waste any time as
he lines it into center field
[Applause]
stella's shooting went out to straight
away center yastrimsky has to go back on
it leaps up its office glove
still is on his way to second he is
going to stop right there
a one-out double
seventh double of the season for tommy
boyle
3-1
that's pulled down the line that's a
fair ball headed toward the corner
stella will score redones on his way to
second
and he is in there standing up rbi
double the angels get on the board it's
5-1 giants
albert pools coming to play could do
some damage taken albert lines went out
to left field of base hit rendon's gonna
be waved around he'll score easily an
rbi single for albert
and the angels deficit is now three good
picture now for the giants will be the
lefty caleb berger trying to get his
team back in the dugout
eventually he got where he wanted it and
up then chased it and the giants hang on
to a three-run lead
look out right back up the middle for a
base hit
down the left field line and a base hit
as he goes the other way
upton's going to have to play the karim
solano stops at third yashrimski's got
another double
second and third
and that's line to center field trout
coming on and he'll dive and make the
catch
the run will come in to score yastrimsky
to third
it'll go as a sac fly six to two san
francisco what a play by trout on that
line drive by landori
that's a good route right away
aggressive route coming in on the
baseball by trout a little jam shot and
a base hit
he flips it over pool holds his head
when you're hot you're hot it's seven to
two
hit on the ground to solano from deep
second and that's the ball game
so in this four game series
two in anaheim and one here
the giants win game three and they do it
behind
a really solid start in a couple of big
flies